i
[Música]
a
[Aplausos]
[Música]
soy uno por siete vivido en colorado mi
nombre es no es nada y no tengo enojado
me llamo nada mal yo lloro por otro piso
todo este este hombre éste cuando
quienes sí se puede se puede cuando
quieres si se puede
cuando tienes si se puede
cuando quieres este acuerdo
[Música]
a vencer
llegando
se presentaría
te lo digo en español no te habla de la
revolución empieza a coro y esta canción
luchar y con su liberación como el pelo
de sal
[Música]
el coche te aleja de las mismas
es mi vida
[Música]
a la vida
a
[Música]
ah
en él
y
[Música]
soy un doctor siente mi palabra de
hambre en mi boca que no es grande
[Música]
e
[Aplausos]
[Música]
e
viva la revolución viva toda mi gente y
que viva nuestra canción viva revolución
viva revolución que vivan los coches
porque todo también 5
[Música]
un abrazo abajo arriba con las familias
arriba arriba abajo el capitalismo abajo
abajo arriba los artistas arriba arriba
que evitar el uso de vivar evolución de
vida toda mi gente y que vivan esta
canción mi vida revolución viva que viva
todos con cierto éxito
[Música]
bajo la policía abajo abajo arriba yo me
sentía mal y va para arriba dando cuando
a la migra abajo abajo boca arriba con
mi abuelita arriba arriba
yo con el racismo abajo abajo arriba los
campesinos
arriba arriba con las paredes
abajo abajo para arriba con las mujeres
[Música]
esa evolución de vida revolución vivida
toda mi gente y que viva nuestra canción
que viva revolución
por siempre porque toca mi 5
[Música]
a
no soy mojado
yo soy humano no soy mojado yo soy tu
hermano no soy mojado yo soy humano no
soy malo yo soy tu hermana de ronson y
en mi barrio evolución de vida todavía
estoy en esta canción que viva
revolución que viva ronson debido a los
votos y este portento también soy tu
querida revolución de vida la evolución
de vida toda mi mente
y
debido a los otros siete porque todo
calificó
[Música]
[Aplausos]